can I use impressive dribbling skills to
successfully fake out your opponents
multiple times
and in the second quarter you made a
jump shot where your body was turned
like 180 degrees away from the basket it
was just an amazing shot you're always
making these spectacular moves with just
within a split second do you anticipate
doing them or is it just a second nature
to you like do you just not even have to
think about it
um you know the way you explain it you
need to be around more often
oh you know I just try to go out and do
the best with the best way I can to try
to you know find ways to better make uh
make some shots and make the right play